hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video von mir sehen ist bereits mit
einbindet freunde wir machen heute eine
ja nein nicht kenne ich natürlich mal
wieder inspiriert von dem lieben sascha
aus stuttgart ii steht euch erstmal die
heutigen teilnehmer hier zweiter vorname
noch immer alkohol carola denke ich
mache ein foto von ihr juli zum glück
übermittelt die kamera keine gerüche
luca der größte spaß tieren der runde
hier das sind die heutigen teilnehmer
dieser challenge meine damen und herren
ein falls ihr nicht wisst dass eine
jahren nicht challenge ist es geht darum
dass uns gleich dass wir uns gegenseitig
fragen stellen und wir dürfen die frage
nicht beantworten mit den wörtern ja
nein nicht und das heißt ich würde
angefangen an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut mein fehler aber wie sieht sich
entscheiden müsst ist zwischen
jägermeister und weißwein wird weiß
warum sie gerade an den tisch in meinem
zimmer unglaublich gern hätte ich eine
sind ein golden retriever finde ich
schön beim fußballspielen zwölf leute
auf dem feld das für die regel
verstanden hast richtig bekommt ja auch
keine richtig richtig bist du gerne hier
schon gerne oder wir waren gestern nach
einer hausparty lasse dort auch das
spiel nicht gemacht hast du denn auf der
house party gefeiert das nicht auf die
couch gelegt für das mir schlafen
gestellt werden dürfte einen drauf
anscheinend schon die den saal
[Musik]
das möchte ich nicht beantworten
das alter ziemlich anders nicht mehr
geben wird
du wohnst wirklich intim
genau diese schule genau ok und machst
du auch deine sachen diesem sommer eher
weniger
wir wollen natürlich muss diese pollen
und staub zugangs und gegen staub und
sebastian pohl
ich kenne ich von pollen schwester
version carola vielleicht kann mir jetzt
fahren kosten 13
bist du denn gern volksnah
definitiv was ist dein lieblingsgetränk
oder ohne alkohol trinkt sehr gerne
wurde warum sprudelt das du warst du
schon mal auf offener see auf jeden fall
weiterlaufen die wurzel oder auch
offenbar sehr genau da im hausboot ist
diese quadratmeter ein hausboot 508500
38 soll auch ein eigenes badezimmer
teilen sie jetzt halt gibt es ein leben
lang gute frage die antwort ist negativ
die wechselt sein können dass die gab es
im kreis mit das war di luca pizza die
war sehr lecker
die war ich habe die ganze zeit
[Musik]
es kommt tatsächlich dieses jahr noch
eine neue pizza heraus das möchte ich an
der stelle nicht wahr
altmann lass mich in ruhe ohne spaß
mit viel freude das muss jetzt mal
ehrlich nicht mehr so auch gestern habe
ich ja nicht nichts aus
denkst du dass kiel ist verdient hätte
deutsche hauptstadt zu sein
eher weniger warum hier klein und es ist
nicht ganz schön für dich
es war für mich eigentlich ein normales
ereignis zu dir ein pickel abdecken
lassen und das ist diesmal das dorf in
den raum gestellt von ja wir haben ja
nicht wir haben ja die frage 50 4
ein paar fragen ich möchte dass es ein
bisschen jemanden ehre verteidigen krise
eine frage okay
okay gesagt was immer mit wörtern nicht
sagen
anders stelle sich wie damen und herren
hier was das hat jetzt ihr vom video
meine damen und herren wenn euch das
ganze gefallen hat was man gerne einen
like daher danke an sascha für die idee
finde ich auf jeden fall megacool das
format und ja das tut ihr das macht die
spielerinnen vor zwei tagen ist meinem
shop eine neue kollektion klamotten
gelaunt und da hab ich mal ganz ganz
ganz ganz kurz eben was zu sagen und
zwar ist leider das tut ihr alter die
server waren leider wieder von 15 uhr
bis 19 uhr ein konzert zu gar nichts
bestellen es lag einfach daran dass
irgendwie wirklich viel zu viele
menschen auf diesem server zugreifen
diese shop zugreifen wollten wir hatten
zugriffe von fünf bis zehntausend leuten
pro sekunde es ist auf jeden fall sehr
sehr leid dass es wieder nicht richtig
geklappt hat mit dem job lounge ihr seid
einfach viel zu heftig unterwegs aber
jetzt kann man auf jeden fall klamotten
bestellen
die reflektierte schon ausverkauft einer
jeansjacke gibt glaube ich noch ein paar
wenige auch nicht mehr alle größen aber
die ganzen anderen sachen sind ja auch
nicht imitiert also schaut gerne mal den
schon vorbei die url ist ducati shop.de
und jetzt sagt die klapse dann auch